[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Philippe Benassaya
vice-président des légal à communication
et aux portes-parola au conseil
départemental des Yvelines bonjour
bonjour alors en 2021 le département est
l'agence Papagayo se sont associés pour
créer la team 78 une team d’influenceurs
qui partage et participe aux événements
dans les Yvelines alors pouvez-vous nous
présenter justement cette team comment
se compose-t-elle alors d'abord on est
on est passé dans une ère dans une aire
totalement numérique à la communication
évolue beaucoup et le département doit
aussi se mettre à la page et nous avons
donc constitué on va reparlé nos en
constitués une équipe une team 78 de
d'influenceurs l'année dernière mais
cette année on remet on remet le couvert
pardonne-moi l'expression on remet ça
puisque ça plutôt bien marché l'année
dernière et aujourd'hui cette équipe
d'affluenceurs influenceuse est composée
de 8 personnes je crois cette femme un
homme donc il y a un homme qui est
totalement isolé au milieu cette cette
influ osseuse ce sont des gens qui sont
globalement à la fois passionnés par par
les réseaux sociaux passionnés par le
département des Yvelines mais également
des gens qui sont dans le métier il y a
des directrices d'agences de
communication il y a des journalistes
bien connus il y a il y a pas mal de
monde il y a même des gens qui viennent
de la société civile pas forcément dans
le milieu des médias mais également donc
que c'est une équipe encore plus
dynamique plus forte que l'année
dernière et on en est quand même très
satisfait mais quelles étaient les
objectifs justement du département au
moment de la création de la team 78
alors justement réfléchissez quand même
il y a un an un peu plus d'un an à
comment promouvoir le département alors
il y a les canaux institutionnels
habituels direction la communication
magazine
dépliant brochure etc bien évidemment
réseaux sociaux mais on a on a réfléchi
à quelque chose de plus de plus direct
de plus dynamique qui touche les gens et
qui touchent les jeunes également donc
bien évidemment c'est porté sur l'idée
d'avoir des influenceurs et des
influenceuses pour en fait non pas
seulement faire la communication du
département du département département
c'est une institution politique mais
c'est également pour
promouvoir la marque Yvelines parce que
Yvelines on va peut-être reparler
également Yvelines est une marque
aujourd'hui c'est une marque du
Paris-Nice c'est une marque pour les
Jeux Olympiques c'est une marque pour
beaucoup d'événements donc c'est devenu
presque une marque publicitaire quoi
donc il fallait vraiment se mettre à la
page et constituer cette team qui a été
constituée en septembre 2021 et qui a
touché beaucoup de monde et on a pu le
voir la team à partager du contenu sur
des événements portés par exemple sur
l'environnement dans les Yvelines ou
encore pour les Yvelines font leur
cinéma alors aujourd'hui les
influenceurs et influenceuses sont
devenus presque essentielles vous l'avez
dit pour faire la publicité d'un
événement un lieu où ici est un
département mais aussi pour une
meilleure communication avec les
internautes alors quel est le bilan
justement que vous faites pour l'année
2021 2022 est-ce que vous estimez que la
team 78 a touché un public était
peut-être différent de la communication
que vous faisiez probablement différent
parce que on a touché des des
des médias tels que Tik Tok Instagram et
toutes ces choses là on n'était pas
forcément habitués dans les Yvelines à
toucher ce genre de public c'est une
première année donc il faut toujours
replacer dans son contexte c'est pas le
c'est pas c'est une première c'est une
première expérience on a globalement
mis en ligne 612 publications dans la
culture sur au niveau de l'environnement
au niveau du sport etc on a touché plus
de 150 000 livres Linois 150 livres
Linois c'est à peu près 14 15% des
habitants des Yvelines donc c'est plutôt
pas mal pour une première année c'est
pour ça qu'on a relancé la deuxième
année
c'est pas mal parce que en fait 150 000
Yvelines noirs on les aurait
probablement en effet pas toucher
pour connaître la communication et pour
connaître la marque Yvelines il faut
aller sur le site des du département il
faut aller sur les canaux habituels
Facebook Twitter faut lire le journal le
magazine on va pas se cacher tout le
monde ne lit pas le magazine des
Yvelines je sais pas si vous le recevez
dans votre boîte aux lettres mais quand
vous le recevez dans votre boîte aux
lettres je sais pas si ça réflexe donc
alors que là c'est une communication
beaucoup plus directe
plus incisives beaucoup plus dynamique
et je pense que pour une première année
c'est un bon bilan pour une première
année alors justement est-ce que cette
team 78 est également là pour
sensibiliser par exemple sur certains
sujets on les a vu sur des thématiques
comme l'environnement est-ce qu'il y a
aussi ce cet objectif de sensibiliser
les Yvelinois des thémates oui parce que
en fait je suis persuadé que si on fait
un sondage dans la rue aujourd'hui je
passe sur que les aiguilles noires
connaissent vraiment
l'importance de ce qu'on a dans les
Yvelines quoi au niveau patrimoine au
niveau architecture au niveau histoire
au niveau sport on a le vélo de Rome on
a le on a le candéloge au niveau culture
aussi on a des grands musées bien
évidemment on a le musée de Nîmes on a
aussi de d'autres Maurice Denis mais on
a d'autres d'autres musées je suis pas
sûr qu'il qu'il connaisse le plan vélo
que nous avons nous avons voté au
département qui est un énorme plan de
circulation 12 dans les Yvelines bref
pardonnez-moi bref c'est quand même
quelque chose quelque chose qui est qui
est très important et je suis pas sûr
que les Illinois connaissent tout ça
donc c'est pour ça qu'on essaye de de
les sensibiliser à travers des canaux
plutôt modernes et vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure on a on a également des
des personnes connues finalement dans
cette dans cette team on afflurant
Florian pardon bio qui a récemment
rejoint le journal télévisé de M6 ou
encore Sandrine arcié présentatrice
journaliste et rédactrice en chef sur C8
ils sont donc comme les autres
influenceurs et influenceuses yvelinois
comment c'est fait cette collaboration
justement avec eux alors c'est un
travail avec l'agence bien sûr l'agence
de communication Papagayo vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure donc il y a un
réseau qui s'est créé il y a il y a des
connaissances communes et puis l'agence
de communication qui est très très forte
a su trouver les mots et les arguments
il y a également derrière
également derrière l'intérêt des
Yvelines et l'intérêt de notre
département pour pour ces personnes là
qui sont pas obligé de le faire
d'ailleurs ils sont pas obligés de le
faire obligé de faire la promotion du
département mais je pense qu'ils sont
conscients de de du potentiel de ce
département avec l'arrivée des Jeux
Olympiques bien sûr dans nos
départements mais également aussi la
richesse et le foisonnement des
activités dans nos départements je pense
que ça compte ça compte aussi dans la
vie d'un journaliste ça compte dans la
vie d'une directrice de la communication
on a des directrices de communication
etc et je pense que c'est également pour
eux une manière d'être des ambassadeurs
des ambassadeurs d'un projet des
ambassadeurs d'un département et je
pense que tout le monde y trouve son
compte alors c'est ça vous avez souligné
justement peut-être sans le vouloir on
appelle ça des influenceurs ou
influenceuses mais vous vous les appelez
les ambassadeurs et ambassadrices des
des Yvelines c'est justement un nom une
fonction voulue pour eux oui parce qu'en
fait ils vont porter ils vont porter les
les la communication ils vont porter la
promotion des des activités des Yvelines
ils vont être l'image des Yvelines à
l'extérieur c'est comme un ambassadeur
une ambassadrice ils vont porter l'image
du département et ils vont expliquer
également ce que nous faisons donc oui
ce sont des influenceurs des parce que
c'est le terme le terme d'aujourd'hui
mais ce sont à la base des ambassadeurs
et sur quels événement justement on
pourrait on pourrait voir cette team 78
cette année alors comme on l'a dit il y
a la culture il y a le sport il y a
l'environnement il y a les Jeux
Olympiques ça fait beaucoup de choses il
y a bien évidemment un peu moins parce
que c'est plus difficile à communiquer
mais il y a tout le volet social des
Yvelines qui est très important mais je
retiendrai pour faire court et clair je
retiendrai surtout l'environnement le
sport et la culture donc
incontestablement pour la préparation
justement aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui seront sur des sur des
événements pour oui oui c'est l'année
prochaine comme vous le savez Paris 2024
et le département des Yvelines
va accueillir à peu près 4 événements
donc ici bien sûr à Saint-Quentin avec
la colline d'Élancourt mais également au
Vélodrome à Versailles à Guyancourt pour
le golf en fait etc donc c'est le moment
et puis je vais vous dire là encore une
fois je suis pas sûr que les aiguilles
noires savent que le Paris-Nice parle du
département des Yvelines chaque année
chaque année ça part d'une ville des
Yvelines moi-même j'étais mère de
Bois-d'Arcy le Paris-Nice est parti de
Bois-d'Arcy il va partir dans quelques
jours de la verrière et du mini Sani
donc voilà ce sont des choses quand même
que l'on fait ce sont des budgets ce
sont des investissements importants et
c'est vrai que on a besoin de ces
influenceurs de ces ambassadeurs pour
pouvoir promouvoir cette image et ses
activités alors en tant que
vice-président déléguée à la
communication du département et aux
portes-parola quel est l'intérêt
justement pour vous d'avoir une team 78
est-ce qu'on peut estimer que
aujourd'hui les départements ou en tout
cas toutes les institutions pourraient
justement être amenées à être un peu
plus sur Instagram et à faire appel à
des influenceurs oui parce que alors
petite parenthèse politique je pense que
l'avenir est au état la décentralisation
même si nous sommes dans une dans un
contexte politique de recentralisation
nationale je ferme la parenthèse je
pense qu'on est quand même à l'avenir
dans un dans un dans une aire de la
décentralisation ce sont les régions les
départements les communes les
agglomérations qui portent les grands
projets aujourd'hui locaux bien sûr
régionaux départementaux et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le département 18 c'est
plus d'un milliard de budget quand même
c'est pas c'est pas rien
et puis non seulement ça mais en plus si
vous comptez l'alliance l'union entre le
les Yvelines et les Hauts-de-Seine ça
devient des supers productions j'ai
envie de dire voilà c'est des
superproductions d'événements et donc
l'avenir je pense c'est à est à la
proximité
l'avenir est à la France d'en bas je
pense aux événements qui partent du bas
et vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure le
cinéma en plein air mais bien évidemment
le Paris Nice les Jeux Olympiques
tous les musées que nous subventionnons
toutes les activités les courses de vélo
les marathons il y a plein de choses qui
se passent moi je bien sûr je balaye
chaque jour toutes les activités qu'il y
a dans les Yvelines dans toutes les dans
toutes les villes des Yvelines c'est
impressionnant et on peut suivre de
toute façon donc toutes les aventures
justement des ambassadeurs et
ambassadrices soit sur le compte
Instagram les Yvelines tout simplement
ou à travers le hashtag team 78 merci
beaucoup
sur sensation et pour voir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]